it could be another controversial
weekend for our president President
Trump the president headed to a big
college football game between Alabama
and LSU the Crimson Tide originally said
students would be punished for booing
but after outrageous school changed its
course NFL legend Terry Bradshaw
weighing in earlier today on Fox and
hats off to him for having the guts to
go in there and do it and I think I'd
respect you have to simply respect the
office of the president United States
it's really right and it's really left
and it's angry and it's ugly in this
hostile I've never seen it like that in
this country Emily but you can't stop
students from doing that's not
constitutional well that was the point
so the back and forth actually was
between the student body president that
came out and was basically like you
don't poo and then the the actual school
came out and said okay you have to abide
by the capstone Creed essentially you
know no no conduct unbecoming a student
and otherwise of course you can exercise
your First Amendment right against the
government whatever I just think that
silence speaks volumes and to me I was
thinking about it like you know I was
raised in greater nation like don't get
me wrong I know how to shout things but
and the president that I didn't agree
with came first of all I would stand for
that office no matter what and secondly
just don't then don't cheer just stay
quiet
like why can't we just do that so Jesse
you got to my mind two schools in red
states Alabama and Louisiana State
University I just it seems to me like a
lot of worry I mean Trump should be
getting a good reception is this a sign
of some problem no you're not gonna get
booed at all on this is gonna get like
an overwhelming amount of applause for
the president this is the deep south
this is Magga country the student
sections Magga country the Alumni
section huge amount of Trump support
there I think the initial thing they
warned it about disruptive behavior
which is like no streaking don't do
anything crazy to embarrass
I don't think there's gonna be no says
she wants drinking I do the game I am
totally gonna watch the game no here's
the thing you think Joe burrows I
definitely think go Tigers but don't get
mad at me if you're from Alabama I think
that the president is exercising
excellent political judgment but also
it's the benefits of incumbency he's
gonna go to the game yeah it's like when
Obama went to the NCAA tournament and
it's like oh that's so cool he gets to
go to that yeah and if you're the
president you get to go so I would
definitely go and also don't forget
there is a governor's race in Louisiana
that and the that election is next
Saturday president Trump went this week
to do a rally to try to help that
Republican candidate to drive beat the
incumbent Democrat that's a very close
race I don't know what's gonna happen
there but it doesn't hurt that the
president is going to this game well it
didn't help in Kentucky did it not for
that particular race but all the other
ones that did I see I see so Greg what
do you think about the idea of booing
cuz you like - boo yes and Pro booing
I'm Pro cheering I'm Pro swearing this
is the news that you get in a golden age
yeah right I I mean we're talking about
booing and not bombing
you can't spell stock market boom
without boo so right now CNN is counting
the amount of times you know Donald
Trump says a specific word they counted
34 times the static expert on to count
that heat that he said this the whistle
blower was inaccurate like 34 times they
had people doing that because they don't
have any news to report they go after
misspellings we're in an age we're in a
great age that we're gonna look like 10
20 30 years from now we're gonna look
back go man we didn't have any problems
when president kanye west's come
but you don't think it says anything
about his weakness that people in red
states are telling the kids don't boo I
I think that this is a this is fake news
you heard that America fake news all
right that was an original